and for the marlins it's sandy alcatra
his 17th start of 2021 coming off the no
decision against toronto but his last
seven starts 179 era and a 198 batting
average he's gone at least at least
eight innings four times this guy has
turned the corner and found a whole
other level
in there
and gashed off the glove
and
able to beat it out that's john verti
the third baseman who was on the right
side of the shift
nothing in two on turner
who is two for eleven three walks in
this series has scored four runs
and into right field it will stay up for
cooper and they've got schwarber
but the throw was a little bit short
now it's up to josh harrison got two
knocks yesterday
that ball out over the plate and the
nationals have the lead location mistake
by the young pitcher and the veteran
harrison made him pay nothing and two on
castro
grounds one to miggy
he will feed jazz at second for out
number three that's get one marlins get
a chance against mad max next
so here's max 26th career start two
complete games and 14 wins against the
fish
well max five pitch mix
it all starts with his fourth team
fastball
he likes to work ahead
and jazz with a fly ball out to left
field schwarber back he turns he looks
it's off the wall
jazz is on his way to second he's not
going to stop there robles throw is not
in time another triple for chess
it's that easy
nationals now with a strike on aguilar
will move the infield in
and a line drive base it down into the
corner that'll get jazz home aguilar is
on his way to second rbi double for
jesus aguilar he's got 51 ribbies in the
marlins to tie things up now that's how
you get it done
and it goes with the fastball
it overpowered the right-handed batter
and they've
got him picked off at second base
avila ranging a little bit too far in
that secondary lead here comes miggy row
there's the throw from sandy and there's
one out
full count pitch with schwarber waiting
on deck
and sandy wins the battle
gets the strikeout his first of the
afternoon
[Music]
swing and a miss
ball skipped into the mid of avila
so for max
that's number two
max again with a 2-2 pitch birdie out
towards center field long run in for
robles and he got there but couldn't
make the catch sanchez went about
halfway he'll get to second easily not
an easy play by any stretch the
imagination for robles a terrific center
fielder
but could not make the play
scherzer down and in with the cutter
third strikeout two in the inning it
took a while max needs a breather
schwarber turner soto coming right up
and he hit the ball extremely hard first
time up
and he hits the ball pretty hard his
second time up from right field and i
think they missed the tag
throw from chisholm tailed away from
aguilar
and kyle schwarber feared just a little
to his right
to touch that bag
do the same thing here at this time too
uncertain swing
that's bats
quiet pretty much all weekend except for
the first few innings on
thursday and if the mats win behind
patrick corbin who pitch well enough to
win a ball game
and max is going to get the change-up
call just off the corner there
make them all like oakland
that ball spinning to the right side and
bell to scherzer
well just like alcantara max could have
gets a very quick third inning
starlin castro fly ball left center
field
sanchez is back in front of the wall and
he makes the catch along fly ball out
sandy is through four one one
[Music]
runner goes and that's a hit and run and
it works to perfection base it into
right field alfaro on his way to third
another multi-hit game for john bertie
that's paying him no mind it's just
about pitcher versus pitcher here that's
a high bouncer but max can just wait and
make the two-handed tag
making sure he secures that ball in his
glove
scrivener's still hitting the ball hard
but it's on the ground now and not in
the air runner goes and roblace is out
strong throw from alfaro
then
marlin's got him on waivers
the following december
great pitch change up down and in
max scherzer another one two three he's
on a big time roll great turner in the
month of june has 25 singles opposing
pitchers have done a pretty good job
lately of keeping trey from driving the
ball
that one's in the air to right
does he do something about that streak
yes sir
c
u
later
that's a single times four and then
that's lead three to one josh bell next
oh bell puts a charge into one
see
you
later way out of here to left center
long distance dialing for the nats
who lead 5-1
banks have been pretty efficient after
the second inning
and el faro helps out by swinging at a
ball for max scherzer out number two and
strikeout number six number eight hitter
john birdies two for two today
up and in with the heater for the
strikeout if that's the last drop out of
the tank it was a good one
chased one alfaro pounces on it throws
to first to complete the strikeout and
we head
to the bottom of the eighth inning
got him in the dirt and the tag and the
eighth is over
that's bullpen two very efficient
innings rainy and both after the
brilliance of scherzer for six innings
but uh you know all in all they were
really just talking about getting martay
back maggie road deep in the hole long
strong throw gets ryan zimmerman for the
final out of the top of the ninth inning
one and two
swing and a foul tip and a strikeout
and in three hours and six minutes the
nats will take care of business